[Música]
é isso ai ai ó paí ó ato sexual de quem
fala andar que sejam muito bem vindos a
amazon eo vídeo de hoje vai ser muito
louco mas o que corre em casa essa sim é
muito grande mas o tamanho da roda quase
do tamanho da minha cabeça lei muito
grande que nem viu esse crime contra o
moto para experimentar aqui no canal foi
reaberto com a parceria com a rbs meu
irmão é muito potente e sergio escadinha
que anda a mais de 70 quilômetros por
hora é muito quilômetros por hora mas
também com essa roda aí tem que andar
muito bem e depois vejam só o controle é
muito lindo meu texto a linha ag
eu sou pra fazer a direção que
possuem que o explorador é e estou muito
ansioso para fazer o texto afora mas
onde o pessoal queria pedir uma coisa
muito importante e você já sabe que você
já sabe eu quero ir muito longe que
neste vídeo pessoal porque só assim eu
sei que vocês vão gostar deste conteúdo
é porque eu já trouxe os dois vídeos com
coisas controlo remoto em aranha o avião
então só de estar aqui neste vídeo com
coisas contra o moto embaixo desse
moleque para receber isso posso fazer
mais e se vocês por acaso nós aqui no
canal passaram aqui e agora não sabem
que eu sou
inscreva se já tivesse nenhum transferir
isto diz que ficou estático sneh e não
só serve muito obrigado mesmo pelo apoio
e embora lá fora lá então é diferente é
antes uma coisa entre 72 comentar o caso
vamos ter que assistir um vídeo só para
ver como o carro funciona né porque esse
cara é muito potente de 60 quilômetros
por hora numa tremenda o casal foi
curtir tudo e eu não quero pegar nem
isso também mandaram esse gozo que muito
louca escolha é muito bonita e inclusive
já teria usado em alguns vídeos a lei e
rosa dos chiques
então o pessoal se quiserem comprar um
relógio um camping deste os links estão
todos lá embaixo vocês podem ver lá
passei lá ninguém mexe eu recomendo
muito são ótimos 2 quiserem comprar
alguma coisa ela é um chute na loja
inclusive tem um vídeo do caminho então
esse vídeo que nós não desistirem 321
para lahij
é muito rápido carro olha eu podendo a
senhora só deus autor por falta de ter
inexploradas
ok também na estrada e se eu já
experimentei um pouco lá fora não estava
chuva
olha aí ela na terra meu deus não foi
aquelas mãos terão prejuízo a quem fica
com o ons a toalha até que não é tão
mais querido e em cima dela sei que vou
ter de implementar e que está tudo em
campo agora o esse metal porque além da
monthal só vamos fazer isso mas tem que
fazer e não clica vai ficar a pé
sua voz ele só querem ver essa conversa
tem que falar o que quiserem desde que
você aqui no canal digam aí que acabou
num caminho muito burro selvagem droga
pulgas apuramento ano eu vou ter que
fazer isso no canal só filme em que
quiserem cunha mago brooklyn e salvo da
montanha e nenhum estava eu vou fazer
mas posso comentar a ida do meia tcheco
também não estilismo é terceiro e andar
por paixão está fazendo surgir ok está
na praia
não acredito espero andar água no
parceiro
tá todo mundo dá pra muito iluminado já
que o solo está é muito bom é muito bom
vamos fazer um estudo hoje e agora vou
lá por fora então experimentar o nosso
carinho e vou te chamar humano é campeão
mais tarde uma bomba lá conhecendo muito
rápido anda documento ea revisão de 30
quilômetros por hora ele olha só 321 vai
revelar quem diga também encontram já
[Aplausos]
o dúvida que essa terra batida eu vou
tentar fazer um grito é que o copom pode
inventar completamente lisa vamos lá ver
se o pneu marca terra agora o o olhar
que esta marca de pneu
[Aplausos]
o u
só porque eu queria passar mas para o
pessoal está normal acontecer porque ela
passa é no vídeo então ela muitas vezes
falta só com podem ver o cartaz de tiro
muito bem aqui a estrada ea terra mas
falta uma coisa ainda está em falta está
na água no solo acho que se eu passar
nenhum tem pouca água eu acho que o caso
vai conseguir só passar e fazer aquela
coisa não dá água tratamento não só
tentar fazer isso por itamar schulle
agora ficou muito sujo é igual
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o povo passou muito perto
veja só comentará o carrinho olha aí a
china leva aqui dentro taxa do planeta
ataque e 80 para assistir é muito
potente e resistente
embora o gol
[Música]
é muito louco dele ensino em dois quando
sozinho não fiz nada só de curva eu vou
perder o carro está muito longe vai
mesmo que eu não fui nem a calma muito
piloto muito rápido só com o vento que
passa os autos o convite é muita
velocidade na rua cento no preço o que
você está achando aqui do caminho que
quiser ver mais vídeos com estes 58
somente porque quer saber e eu mesmo
quero fazer mais gols mas só se vocês
gostarem de ver o conteúdo aqui para
limpar a casa e usar a nossa ampla na
piscina mas fica já prontinho só fica já
perguntei vocês acharem muito aqui neste
vídeo eu vou para um parque de skate
onde taxa dos amplos e vamos tentar usar
o nosso carinho lá
imagino que em off pai assim só assim
isso é muito louco então deixei muito
aqui neste vídeo o mesmo e pode ela pra
casa vamos usar a nossa reta entre china
e cuba mas já construída a rampa piscina
que se está a poluir o homem procurado
uma planta aqui então eu acho que então
não sei qual é o plano o plano agora é
montar a minha campanha porque ela não
está montado ainda eu quem vai apanhar
boas desde aqui e vai ter um lar que tem
que atravessar obrigatoriamente precisa
olha aí sim hum
você vai funcionar só mas deixei muito
mais que comentei o que vocês acham que
vocês acham que isso vai funcionar como
tem batata
se vocês acham que não vai funcionar e o
caso vai cair na água como em bekaa e
não sei quem vai ganhar a equipa da
batata a equipa do bic blá
o iêmen vai assim tao a campo nesta
manhã o irmão pessoal esta é nossa
campanha agora vamos aproximar a rampa
de piscina e tentar aproveitar ao máximo
balanço
sim vai o oovoo ou se foi com muita
força mas à tarde mesmo quero muito
conseguir ser e só deixei muito claro
que eu quero mas se for sair embora mas
pronto sim 320 completamente na água
olha aí o comitê está funcionado e eu
crio oito funcionários pessoal
como podem ver com seu chuveiro muito
taxa e muito a nossa rampa dali o nosso
cartão talão e caxumba e eu ainda tentei
usar a mesma mas com o pneu do carro
também estava molhado então eu dou tudo
não vou conseguir fazer agora a rampa
mas pelo menos nós conseguimos fazer um
salto época em que uma piscina e mesmo
assim funciona bem em cima dele o time
porém que as pessoas precisam estar
daqui deste vídeo já sabem se quiserem
comprar alguma coisa negra mas temos
noite embaixo e não é nada difícil
comprar é só assisto assinarem o vosso
país que o método de pagamento o que
contar que contactem só deixei muito
lixo não for inscrito no canal inscrevam
se espera de um estado fique mais até a
próxima
[Música]